والبدايه مع مراسلنا عيسى الطيبي من قاعده
رامشتاين العسكريه الامريكيه حيث يجتمع
وزراء دفاع مجموعه الاتصال العسكريه
الخاصه
باوكرانيا فقد دعى وزراء الدفاع الامريكي
لود اوستن الوزير دعا من وصفهم بالحلفاء
لزياده دعبهم العسكري لاوكرانيا بينما قال
زنسكي الذي شارك في الاجتماع عبر الفيديو
انها حكومته تتوقعوا قرارات قويه من
مسؤولي الدفاع
اذا عيسى الان معنى مباشره
قويه هل تحقق له ما يريد
عندما قال الف تحيه لكم ولكن نريد الف
دبابه توقفه الشر رد عليه وزير الدفاع
الالماني بان الاجتماع لن يكون لاقرار
ارسال اي دبابه ايضا تحدث وزير الدفاع
الالماني بان المجتمعين لم يناقشوا اصلا
ارسال الدبابه الامريكيه ام واحده برانس
وهي نقطه مفصليه كان الحديث
السابق يقول بان قمه رانشتاين او اجتماع
مشتاين سيكون اجتماع الدبابه الامريكيه
ولا المانيه ايضا هو وزير الدفاع الالماني
ان الدبابه الالمانيه اليوبارد اثنين لن
يتم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا كان هذا السؤال
المفاجاه طبعا كان جواب الوزير المفاجاه
لماذا لانه قال بان بان لدينا مسؤوليه
تجاه ومسؤوليه سياسيه همم هي التي اقتضت
ان تتخذ هذا القرار وقال باننا مستعد لبحث
امكانيه ارسال هذه النوع من الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا وفقت حاء اتفاق مع الحلفاء طبعا
اذا اردنا ان نوفق بين الروايات روايه
البنتاجون عندما قال بانهم من غير
المطروحه نزوده اوكرانيا بالدبابه ام واحد
ايضا والتصريح الذي ادلى به وزير الدفاع
الالماني نصل الى خلاصه بان اجتماع
رمشتاين سوف لن يكون اجتماع الدبابات لن
يزود اوكرانيا بالدبابات وهذا هو المخرج
الذي تم التاكد منه النقطه الثانيه وهي ما
قاله الوزير بان بان دعمه اوكرانيا دعمها
اوكرانيا بالدبابات سيكون ذلك ووفقه
ايطالي وجمعي مع حلفائنا لنستمع ما قاله
وزير الدفاع الى المانيا
مسؤوليه
لحمايتها وعلينا ان نتشاورك قبل اتخاذ اي
قرار بشان تزويدي اوكرانيا بالدبابات فهذا
لن يكون قرار يتخذوا في المستقبل القريب
وقد ذكرت بكل وضوح ان المانيا لن تتوقف عن
مساندتي اوكرانيا ولن ناخذ لهم سنواصل دعم
اوكرانيا مهما طالت هذه الحرب